first and foremost congratulations uh
what are you feeling and getting this
opportunity to kind of come back and and
how would you say this character define
your life thank you yeah i mean
it's just been an incredible opportunity
to get to continue with this character
and come back to star wars after all
these years the grand inquisitor means
nothing
kenobi is all that matters now this is a
role that has had a huge impact on my
life
um you know professionally and
personally
uh so to to get to continue my journey
with them is hugely meaningful
yeah you know you told us here not me
personally but here at et over 20 years
ago that in preparing for to play anakin
involved buffing up a bit what kind of
commitment to have you made
uh well right now i'm you know trying to
get in shape and uh
buff up a little bit so i want to ask do
you have to get in shape to do this
again or is this part of your your
regular physique that fits the character
now yeah i know it's a star wars
requirement um
i i uh for this one even more so because
i'm playing vader now and so i put on as
much weight and size as i could i think
i think i put on about 25 pounds wow but
uh yeah so just eating a lot a lot of
food and working out
what have you become
am
what you made me
we are especially excited obvious to see
you and and you win together on screen
what is it about your guys relationship
that you kind of value the most that you
look forward to in this process i mean
we just there's a lot of history there
you know and and we
we we shared a very sort of special
experience when we were filming the
prequels uh and we became really close
because of our time spent on those films
getting to come back and
and work with him again has been amazing
uh but just getting to you know
reconnect with with with my old friend
uh has really been nice that's awesome
to hear man when i talked to him he kind
of uh very much mimicked exactly what
you're saying and it really you can feel
a great deal of respect between you two
so just so exciting for us us viewers us
fans of these franchises
you should have killed me
when you had the chance
i want to ask real quick uh how big is
your daughter i have a seven-year-old
son and i'm kind of just
introducing him to all this stuff and
it's really cool because you guys are
coming back and i've been fans of you
guys for so long and now you're doing
new stuff and i get to bring him into it
how big a fan is your daughter i know
you're kind of a self-proclaimed disney
guy is there any added excitement now
that it's kind of part of the mouse
house you know this is a disney show
it works really well being a dad now um
and having the whole the whole disney
aspect to it yeah i mean that's
definitely been sort of a part that's
been really special for me too is just
getting to share this experience with my
daughter who's also seven you know i
haven't i haven't shared any of the
films with her yet
so she hasn't actually seen star wars
but you know she obviously knows about
it and she knows you know the character
that i play yeah she was my first
lightsaber training partner when i
started on this
yeah
they were in the house you know
clashing lightsabers
i love that so much i mean there's no
child out there that isn't um fascinated
by a lightsaber yeah right yeah and it's
super cool i i didn't know i didn't know
your daughter was seven but that's
awesome so i know exactly i know exactly
the fun that it is
there can be no mistakes you're certain
the tracker is with you
yes my lord
i want to talk real quick kind of before
i let you get out of here i i spoke with
you and about this and the fans seem to
be giving moses a hard time and and kind
of you know commenting negatively about
something it's baffling because it's
like the same fans that love this
franchise are kind of beating up some of
its new stars i've heard a little bit
about that and
obviously it really saddens me i think
the world of moses you know she's
not only a lovely person and human being
but but incredibly talented actress the
first time i saw uh the first couple of
episodes
i was blown away by her performance and
and and just thought that this sort of
subtleties and nuances that she brought
to this character were
were there and and really impressive and
um so i mean i hope i hope by the end of
this series
you know people are coming around but uh
i think i think she's done a great job
and i think it's it's an important
character and um
and people will will come to realize
that
[Music]